hello everyone and welcome to an
absolute treat uh for those of you who
enjoyed the martial attack we have a
rest day in the World Chess Championship
and uh for today I thought I'd show you
a nice game between former world
champion vishwanathan Anand and a true
legend of Chess John nun now none was
not a world champion but nonetheless he
is like I said a true legend of Chess
I'm not exaggerating here and for those
of you who are only hearing about him
for the first time I urge you to go
online look up John Nunn and whatever
you find interesting about him you post
in the comment section below like any
anything that you really uh consider
that people should know uh do that and
uh you know increase everyone's vast
knowledge but getting back to this game
uh why am i showing you this game well
my father-in-law visited from Germany uh
yesterday and today we had uh we had a
beer and we talked about the world's
championship and you know what's been
going on the the progress of Chess over
the last 20 years or or so and we
discussed the openings that are being
played as he enjoys open games I enjoy
open games I we don't really
particularly enjoy close games and so we
got to the topic of the martial attack
and I said okay in the previous World
Championship we never had the martial
attack we always had the anti-martial
nipple and never really gave Magnus a
chance for for going for the martial
attack and also In This World Chess
Championship nipple does not allow ding
the the chance to go for the martial
attack he often deviates with an early
D3 uh or or in game two he deviated even
earlier than that so chances are That
We're Not Gonna See the Marshall
especially now in the second half of the
world show Championship when Dean even
went for the Berlin uh chances for a
martial appearance on worldchester
Championship is getting uh quite thin so
that's that's why I I uh I went online I
started checking on what are the
greatest games ever played in the
martial attack dating all the way back
to the legendary capablanca versus
Marshall game and I found this one it's
it's it's a absolutely remarkable and
you guys will enjoy it and I I you know
we spoke a lot about uh different lines
I said that that I really hated when
white captures the Knight on C6 but it's
a it's a very rare line pretty much no
one plays it and I was uh very
interested uh when I saw here at this
game where Anand actually captured it so
let's check it out let's see uh why this
is so incredible and why John nun is
such a legend so here it was played in
Hugo vein in 1919 and uh I'm not gonna
spoil the tournament uh before we check
out the game so I don't play spawn to E4
uh we have Pawn to E5 Knight to F3 and
now Knight to C6 let me just shift to
this over here sorry about that uh there
we go
uh
so Knight to C6 with Bishop to B5 going
for the rui Lopez and now Pawn to A6
morphe's defense Bishop to A4 we have
Knight to F6 and now we have castles we
have Bishop to E7 uh Rook to E1 B5 and
Bishop to B3 we have castles and now
white uh definitely challenges black
here on and plays Pawn to C3 and he
allows Jon to go for the martial attack
and he does spawn to D5 and of course uh
Anand accepts it it is the best way to
counter the martial e captors on the
five Knight captures on D5 uh here my
father-in-law also uh discussed Ponte E4
I've actually never seen this move he uh
showed it to me and I was like that's
even an option and yes that's an option
you really should know if you uh you
know play against the Marshall because
it's it's really scary but okay that's a
topic for uh for a different line here
uh we have captors on the five night
Captain D5 Knight captures and E5 Knight
captures and Rook captures on E5 so the
absolute main line of the Marshall Pawn
to C6 and uh sorry uh previously I said
Bishop captures and C6 I meant Bishop
captures on D5 because here the main
moves are D3 D4 you can bring the Rook
back to E1 you can even bring the Rook
back the E2 even that has been played uh
but here Bishop captures on D5 by Anand
uh very rare C captures on D5 and now
Pawn to D4 so The Rook is now nicely
defended uh you've opened up your
position and you are ready to start
developing your pieces because you
really should do that as white so here
Bishop to D6 challenges The Rook Rook to
E3 you can also go Rook D1 Rook D3
is preferred here as you know that the
queen is coming into the game Quinta H4
now threatening to capture on H2 and not
not the G3 as you would expect in the
mainland of the Marshall but here with
this particular setup uh Pawn to H3
Anand knows his stuff of course this is
the best move here and now Pawn to G5
very scary uh and Ireland plays Pawn to
B3 just ignoring this advance and
unplates B3 which is of course the best
move by the engine and it is now as of
move 16 we have a position that has
never been reached before and it was of
course new at the time it was played and
here Ponta F5 really going all out
against Anand not holding anything back
we have Queen to F3 Anan develops the
queen goes after the D5 pawn bishop to
B7 and now Rook the E6 putting pressure
on the bishop here but John
effectively counters this with Rook 88
now of course Rook captures Bishop would
not be uh would not be great because it
is met with Rook day one it's a very
scary line because after uh let's say
captures Rook day one with checking th2
you don't have Checkmate as the bishop
is now gone but will capture Sun C1
again really cripples wide really
hinders the development of his pieces
and I mean yes the the black king is is
kind of wide open but uh first of all of
course noon forced the the the Marshall
noon prepare for this Anand knows that
he would not have a great time in this
position so instead
after Rook 88 we have real characters on
E8 Rook captures and now King the F1
stopping of course Rook to E1 Checkmate
and now Pawn to G4 uh Queen captures on
F5 and now G captures on H3 and now you
have to capture the problem is if
something like Queen to G5 you force a
queen trade you again run into H2 and
now it's just uh game over there's no
defense against this so Queen captures
an H3 and here you might expect okay
black has all of these pieces eyeing the
the white king surely uh John will just
move the queen with something like Queen
T4 but no John actually trades queens
and here look at his captors captures
and now Bishop to C8 truly a remarkable
move uh anand's King has no squares look
at the bishop pair the the bishop pair
is most certainly fully operational and
the problem is if you clicking the G2
now just uh Rook day one and Anand has
no way of developing if Bishop to B2
looks like you're doing good progress
just Rook to D1 again an island has no
moves here like how do you even make a
move at some point you will have to
sacrifice a pawn with C4 but um it's not
not the best of course Knight A3 is met
with the simple Rook captures on A1 and
you lose a piece here so uh you know
it's definitely slim pickings here so
after Bishop to E3 which again is the
best uh according to the engine uh
Bishop captures an H3 with the check
King to E2 and now Bishop G4 check here
we have a repetition of of a sword sorry
King to D3 Bishop F5 checking T2 Bishop
G for checking D3 Bishop F5 check King
E2 I'm sure that uh Anand would have
been very happy with the draw here but
Jon does not allow it feel free to pause
the video and try to find the move that
Jon played while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on solving this
position as it's uh well just a complete
bind on on from White's perspective and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Rook the C8 and now look
at this what can Anand play he can't
move a piece he can't move a single
piece if he moves the Knight then he
loses the C3 Pawn he can't move the Rook
he can't really move any pawns he can
play Pawn to C4 and this is uh this
could very well be the best movie that
uh he can make it wasn't played but uh
let's say you give a pawn here Rook
captures on C4 now you can develop the
Knight and now Rook the C2 and this is a
position you would have to survive with
the material being equal but black has
the mighty Bishop pair The Rook is
extremely active I mean it's a very
difficult position to play Anand instead
played Pawn to F3 and now we have King
to F7 Jon starts bringing the king into
the game Bishop to D2 the pawn is now
defended but just spawn to H5 Jon says
what are you even doing where is your
night going Anand have played Fantasy 4
now comes Rook to E8 with check King to
F2 and now Bishop to D3 going after that
The Rook D2 check that then again
there's really no square for the Knight
you develop uh the Knight you could try
it let's say Knight to C3 but then B4
chases away the Knight and then you give
a check and then you win material so
instead Anan played Bishop back to E3
there's really nothing better now Pawn
to H4 we have Pawn to F4 blocking the
bishop now D captures on C4 B captures
Bishop B captures and now Knights the D2
finally Anand gets the develop his
pieces but now Rook the B8 preparing to
bring the Rook into the game King the F3
sidestepping the second Rank and now
Pawn to C3 uh Knight the E4 we have
Bishop to B4 you could also Play Bishop
to E7 it also seems like it kind of
counters the Knight but this is much
much better and now Rook the D1 the uh
the only way to survive here is to play
something like A3 but it would be uh
like okay the engine says maybe if an
engine plays you will survive but if a
human play is not real let's say Rook to
D1 hero attacks the bishop let's see
trades captures captures and pawn to H3
uh this doesn't look like something you
can you can defend but it is the White's
best chance but here we have Rook to D1
attacking the bishop and here uh Jon
just played Bishop capture 74 King
captures and pawn to see too and he was
in this position on move 41 that
vishwanathan Anand resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
once you move the Rook end it doesn't
really matter where you move it let's
say Rook to C1 you attack the pawn Rook
the C8 defends the pawn and now King the
D3 uh let's say you play something like
this just Rook captures a rook to C3
check the king will move and now Bishop
to A3 attacks the rook and that's pretty
much it once The Rook moves you will
promote the pawn to a queen and that's
it you don't even have to do that you
can even play captures captures and now
bring a Queen into the game this will
make your position completely winning
Europa full piece and of course there's
no question about it so uh the
definitely an enjoyable game I was so
happy that this is the first one I
checked because when I went online to
search for a famous Marshall games the
first three I checked were the ones that
I uh already seen and I think I've even
shown them on the channel but the fourth
one uh Anand versus John Nunn I haven't
seen it and I was so happy when I when I
checked that it was actually the captors
on D5 line uh because that that was the
line that I was discussing with my with
my father-in-law so we we had a board
that we checked it and it was absolutely
incredible so I I thought uh okay now
today's the rest day that's exactly what
I'm gonna show you guys uh because it's
beautiful I mean you guys might also be
more interested in enjoying the Marshall
and if you face the martial off and uh
also you can take something from this
game because Anan played a great game I
mean he he made no serious mistakes
pretty much every move that Anand made
was like second or or sometimes first or
sometimes third recommendation from the
engine it's just that the move John
played was pretty much always the first
recommendation by the engine so this is
truly truly a masterpiece and this was
1990 way before the era of the engine so
that's why uh John nun is an absolute
Legend and if you if you ever have a
chance to pick up a John Nunn book or
check out the John on game uh you guys
should definitely do so so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it
um I I mean I'm always very happy when I
get to see a nice martial attack game uh
I would like to thank Max Sally Ricky
black Igor Savage Martin Cara and Jordan
Smith for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World tomorrow we are
continuing the World Chess Championship
between uh dingler and the Yani promise
and of course we are hoping that a
marshall will appear on the board at
least in one of the games so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
find anything interesting on John uh
posted in the comment section below see
you soon